der einzige gewinner heute abend aber
vielleicht könnte auch noch ein
trauriger gewinner werden des olaf
scholz olaf scholz hat ein comeback
hingelegt
wie ich kenne nichts vergleichbares in
der politik armin holz armin schild
armin laschet
brutales wahlergebnis für die spd für
die cdu meine güte was mit mir los ist
armin laschet hat die cdu bei 36 prozent
übernommen bei 36 prozent dieses jahr im
januar und auf 25 prozent geführt das
ist absolut dramatisch klaus hat es eben
angesprochen bei den grünen hat man vom
kanzleramt geträumt hat man sich mit
möbel auswahl für das büro der
bundeskanzlerin beschäftigt jetzt nach
dieser ganzen plagiat affäre um annalena
baerbock hat annalena baerbock die
grünen aus dem kanzleramt heraus wieder
auf den boden der tatsachen bei rund um
15 prozent geführt in diesen sekunden
wird außer bei der spd ganz viel darüber
gesprochen wer hat hier eigentlich
vergeigt und dieses wahlergebnis
bedeutet wir werden da eine nacht der
langen messer in allen parteien zu
wählen die bilder aus den
parteizentralen da hat sich in der spd
schon viel publikum angesammelt bei der
cdu sei es vorhin deutlich leerer aus
ein kleiner kleine seiten beobachtungen
übrigens noch in den vergangenen jahren
haben ja die umfragen oft sehr sehr
daneben gelegen und das ist ja im
prinzip ein ergebnis das eigentlich den
letzten umfragen fast haargenau
entspricht das kommt ein bisschen drauf
frau an wie sie am ende aussieht ja es
gab gestern noch eine umfrage die hatte
26 spd 25 cdu hat die forschungsgruppe
jetzt auch auf 24 bei der cdu aber
trotzdem direkt und 20 million zwar
nicht wer da dran an dem was wir bei
bild mit insel hatten das ist das ist
jetzt noch ein bisschen bewegung drin
aber insgesamt im trend haben die
forschungsinstitute richtig gelegen was
vielleicht nicht ganz abgebildet weil in
den letzten wochen war sozusagen das
comeback der cdu ja das ist jetzt hier
egal ob sie am ende vorne liegen oder
hinten stärker ausgefallen als es in den
analysen abgebildet war für alle
wählerinnen und wähler zu hause jetzt
wieder sitzen und sich diese zahlen
anschauen vielleicht jetzt gerade erst
einschalten und sich fragen ja was denn
nun was bedeutet das denn jetzt wie es
denn jetzt fast uns bitte einmal
zusammen klaus oder ich will ja wer
möchte zuerst was das genau jetzt zu
diesem zeitpunkt bedeuten könnte weil
die menschen die jetzt zu hause sitzen
und das gerne weil dotierte also ich bin
ja denkt er gern in einfachen struktur
und deshalb denke ich mal im bewährten
bündnissen also schwarz und gelb müsse
jetzt die grünen rumkriegen für jamaika
oder rot und grün
müssen die fdp rumkriegen für die ampel
na herzlichen glückwunsch das ist
wirklich also sozusagen so gekreuzt dass
man auch schon spürt dass es passieren
kann dass es gar kein wirklicher
mehrheit gibt und er bekennt ja meine
angst alle gespräche dieser art führen
ins nichts und dann muss halt die große
koalition weitermachen übrigens weil
zwischen spd und cdu die unterschiede ja
nicht größer sind als zwischen grünen
und fdp also das bedeutet die große
koalition zusammen zu raufen gegen den
mehrheitswillen der leute ist einfacher
als eine dieser beiden koalitionen das
ist ein ganz entscheidender punkt in
klaus gerade sagt wenn wir jetzt auf die
ergebnisse schauen und wir sehen sie
gerade nochmal eingeblendet die größte
mehrheit mit der größtmöglichen
inhaltlichen überschneidungen ist
tatsächlich gerade eine große koalition
da habe ich eine klare mehrheit
50 prozent sowohl die ard als auch zdf
unterschiedliche verteilung aber 50
prozent
und wir haben ja nun die zehn jahre
miteinander regiert und wir wissen da
gibt es inhaltliche überschneidungen
dies zb grünen und fdp in keiner weise
gibt
[Musik]